[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Fox ster I'm Constance and kisum
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts before
I introduce our fantastic guests this
week I should just explain something
our producer had a brilliant idea this
week of how to improve the show which
turned out to be to cut us out from this
episode completely so that's what's
going to happen absolutely so you will
notice that it's going to be mainly
focused on Melissa and not on our faces
which to the majority of people ie
99.99% recurring that will be an
improvement yeah well we have fired him
now and replaced them with a half
trained monkey so you will see the
quality of the show improve in the
coming weeks but anyway so what you're
going to see is Melissa answering some
of our questions there will be a little
bit of us but mostly will be a slide up
with with the text of the question that
we asked her if you want to listen to
the actual conversation with our usual
top level banter and stuff like that go
to the podcast that will be available
completely uncut as or as normal the
only problem is that like I said we
completely lost the footage of our
camera this week so that's why it is the
way it is with that in mind
enjoy Melissa Chen who's the newly
appointed editor of The Spectator in New
York she's a brilliant journalist
extremely talented and we had a great
conversation as you're about to see
when he doesn't have you I tell us a
little bit about who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
that leads you to sit in this chair in
front of these cameras um well so I'm
originally from Singapore born and bred
and which in an office office is a bit
more unique I think you probably rarely
have any guests from Singapore and I
made my way to the US maybe when I was
17 I always said I came in for a
education but I stayed for the civil
liberties Singapore is pretty repressive
as a society and I grew up under
conditions where you know I knew what it
was like to not be able to speak freely
so I've always been very Pro free speech
but that having said I mean no no
complaints growing up there was one best
places to have it you know had a
childhood very prosperous little country
and kind of interesting on the political
spectrum as well not neatly defined as
left or right so that also informs my
own full view in politics pretty much
and so I came to the US study actually I
did science it was a scientist for quite
a few years and then met Nawrocki
refugee by the name of Faisal and we
found it an NGO together we deal with
sort of Middle East issues translating
texts of the Enlightenment popular books
by Steven Pinker Sam Harris all into
Arabic and making them digitally
available for free long before anyone
who wants to read them Arabic Farsi and
Kurdish any idea is to challenge
orthodoxy in the Middle East challenge
censorship and and try to bring in
plural ideas right so that's that's what
I did
and recently joint spectator USA because
they finally after I mean it was a long
time coming it was found in 1828 and
here in the UK and finally went over to
the other side and in print as well so
you'll be able to read me and all my
musings and political you know ramblings
on on spectator you as a well that's
actually one of the reasons we were keen
to have you on the show because we have
been reading your ramblings and your
musings and you've been quite clear
about your views on China and your Han
Chinese in my right
I'm half yeah huh yeah and that's an
issue that a lot of our audience have
been clamoring for us to start
addressing which is Hong Kong and China
more broadly so let's dip into that I
remember we were talking before we
started the show when Donald Trump was
running for president and you know
people making fun of him because he was
talking about China making it a big
issue but from what you've written my
sense is that you are pretty comfortable
that is the major issue that is
confronting the United States and more
broadly the Western world right now the
well the entire world that the China
issue is is really kind of the linchpin
issue of our time I think it's it's the
new Cold War it's it's the new dividing
line on on where people stand in terms
of what kind of world do we want do we
want to Pax Americana or pec Seneca what
world order do we want do are we going
to abandon the liberal world order that
was established after World War two and
what's gonna take its place that's
really what China represents and it's
it's the way things are evolving is is
pretty interesting countries are lining
up and taking sides in this right so
Russia China there's this new axis and
then they're the new allies and you know
the question of for our time is well
which side are the people who live in
the free societies like we do what were
they going to stand and what is the
situation like in China at the moment
with regards to Hong Kong well I mean
it's so hard to find out what happens in
China because it's everything's
controlling state media is the only
media around you don't have you have you
know basically Facebook Instagram all
these social media companies are not
allowed in China so it's it's unless you
know people there and talk to people on
the ground it's pretty difficult to get
any word out tell us about the Hong Kong
issue like just for anyone who saw a
news report once three weeks ago and
those are some people are protesting
Hong Kong just break that down for us so
anyone doesn't know anything about it
I've been to Hong Kong a couple of times
it's a great place and lovely people but
that doesn't necessarily mean I know
anything about it and then be the case
for a lot of people as well so Hong Kong
has been for
past four months sort of engulfed in
protests they've they're calling it the
pro-democracy protests if you are
following on Twitter those are the
hashtags that are trending and every
weekend almost you know you have throngs
I mean really throngs one in a bit speak
one in seven Hong Kongers were on the
streets taking to the streets for the
most part part peacefully protesting but
they have been violent escalations every
now and then but they are disruptive
they do disrupt you know train schedules
and even sometimes the airport sit-ins
but what their protest they know what
they were what it started out was that
it started out as a protest against an
extradition law that Hong Kong tried to
pass Carrie Lam eventually who's the
exact chief executive of Hong Kong
eventually cancelled it because of the
protests like several months in it was
just getting way too crazy and what that
extradition law would have allowed was
anyone that basically China wanted could
be extradited from Hong Kong to face
trial in China and the thing about
trials in China is that it's pretty much
up to the whims of the Chinese Communist
Party of the CCP and you know if you're
dissidents if you are a bookseller who
has been selling sort of you know books
that were not sanctioned you could just
be disappeared and end up in mainland
China for show trials that has happened
before the extradition law passed so
with it this now allows us to happen
under very legal framework so this was a
clear violation of the treaty the joint
you know the joint treaty signed between
Britain and Hong Kong when in China when
Hong Kong was handed over in 1997
because it was a British colony for so
many years along with in Macau is
another colony as well so in the end
they canceled the extradition law but
but the protest sort of morphed into
something a bit bigger became about
wanting universal suffrage because
doesn't exist there it became about
accountability because the police was
actually really brutal to the protesters
so they were demanding for for some
accountability for that
and I think there are five core demands
of the of the protesters one of them is
actually not about independence so it's
got nothing to do with actual
independence the chinese state media
will call it a separatist movement it is
not because it's not one of the five
core demands in fact I think the only
the only people that are saying that are
people buying into the apologetics of
the Chinese Communist Party
they did and in fact one of the first
pieces I wrote about this was actually
for aerial magazine helen pluck Rose was
my very gracious editor and a former
guest of us yeah exactly
and I wrote about how because at the
time you know the when the protests
first started kind of people were very
confused because well the Western media
was very confused or they didn't seem to
know how to address this but the Hong
Kong protesters were waving at British
like the Union Jack they were waving the
American star-spangled banner and they
were singing the national anthem and to
see you know the former in the
inhabitants of her former colony raised
a colonial flag it was very jarring to
woke eyes right at our time so it was it
was confusing and I wrote an article
about how post-colonial theory kind of
affects how we see the the protesters
and and their plight and you know the
fact that we can't really process that
right now in in modern terms at least in
the West Western media and and that if
it wasn't for the British legacy there
would be nothing to protest about right
so that is one of the complications of
this I mean to even talk about maybe one
of the things that British rule brought
to Hong Kong that was worth holding on
to
which is a point that's very difficult
to make today because decolonization
movements and everything and that seem
is just something that was a very nasty
period in in human history and there's
no other way to look at it zero but here
was a bit of a contradiction that that
the protesters were were holding up a
symbol of freedom and and had it not
been for British common law brought
through colonial rule that they would
not be fighting for the very thing that
they are fighting for now
um I would say that what's interesting
about the Hong Kong issue is that it is
one of the rare issues that drew
bipartisan support in Congress at least
Lipson us right right so you had even
senator Elizabeth Warren coming out and
supporting the Hong Kong protesters and
you know so are many people on the right
like Marco Rubio so there is at least
consensus verbally but in terms of
passing resolutions or supporting the
trade war there is a bit of a divide I
think I think the left is definitely
more critical about the trade war
whether is it whether it is because it's
Trump perpetuating it I don't know
because it's one of those things where I
do remember a time when the Democrats
were a lot more in favor of
protectionist trade policies for as you
see the flip where now the the
Conservatives are actually very Pro
trade war that we need to do this sort
of stem China's power it's going to hurt
them more than us this is an issue of
national security and therefore we
should prioritize national security over
economics over what's gonna be
comfortable we're gonna lose probably
you know jobs GDP economic growth is
gonna be sluggish because of it but it's
a worthwhile trade-off because this is a
national security issue so that's where
the right stands on the trade war and of
course Trump supporters are just all in
you know and if you talk to well I have
friends that are journalists and some of
them talk to farmers up in the Midwest
they said that many MIT Westerners who
grow soybeans know that well because of
the trade or China is not going to be
buying them but they kind of see that as
a necessary bullet to bite mm-hmm which
is which is interesting to see that kind
of response
as of this moment nervous so for the
trade war is what Trump had implemented
was a series of tariffs some of them
incremental but mostly on agricultural
products and and other United States
exports into its China and likewise he
also had tariffs on imports into the
United States to protect certain
industries make it difficult basically
for both countries to trade it penalized
the theory was that it penalizes China
more and therefore because it's gonna
hurt them more that they would come to
the bargaining table to talk about other
things and and you know Trump is always
he be he in fact he's been campaigning
this has been one of his campaign
promises that China's been treating us
very unfairly also in the labor markets
you know we need to push back on them
it's been unfair trade practices look at
the account deficit so he's been kind of
consistent on this actually and the fact
that he's kind of made this a central
piece right now his of his agenda is
very much consistently in line with what
he's been saying even when he was
campaigning where it is now is that
they've kind of agreed not to escalate
the the trade war currently so I think
the there is an agreement between China
and the United States and last I
remember that the tariffs that are still
in place to to be enacted in September
and November are still in place but for
now the trade war scene there seems to
be a temporary truce my time just goes
out this yes and any spark like the NBA
situation could just make it worse and
that happens so quickly well before we
get on to the NBA I have listened to
Donald Trump talk about China quite a
bit I've never heard him really say that
much about Hong Kong is that because
I've been listening to the wrong thing
or is it yeah or is it a big issue in
his in his mind well Phil there was one
thing that he did say that you know was
a very positive development for for
people who are in the Hong Kong side he
said that it would be very bad for China
if they took any military action against
Hong Kong so there were troops rolling
in or anything there was a bit of a
a warning that it would be bad for China
what that meant no one knows but it was
a tweet as usual I'm sure it was well
considered right so I think a lot of
people are disappointed that he couldn't
say anything more but on the other hand
I understand that he has to you know
consider a lot of jobs I mean I wish he
could be far more forceful than he has
been and and sort of pushing for things
on the on the Hong Kong supporter side
but any of the day Hong Kong's going to
go back to China
20:47 officially but one country two
systems'
that's gonna be abolished in 2047 what
is really the endgame for the people of
Hong Kong I mean it's you know the
longer the stores out really its China's
advantage just because of the terms of
the treaty and what's going to happen
either way so it's it's hard to see what
what the goal is there I guess what is
highlighted to the world is the reality
of what China is correct and China's
huge power which is where we come to the
NBA because for anyone who didn't follow
the story Daryl Morey who's the general
manager of the Houston Rockets made a
comment supporting the protesters in
Hong Kong have you just tweeted a
photograph my photograph said stand for
freedom fight with Hong Kong right a
fight for freedom staying with Hong Kong
right there are many ways that China's
infiltrated and and it's able to
influence our economic systems even
academia it's pretty scary but you know
tell us more about that well I mean the
thing was historically if the the the
thinking was that as China you know
liberalized its economy and introduced
market reforms and got more wealthy and
we started engaging with trade in trade
with them that eventually they'll have
no choice especially with the internet
there they're going to have to open up
you know once new ideas kind of reach
their shores and along with rising
affluence because of market reforms that
China's just going to allow political
freedoms to creep back in and slowly
open the country up that by far was one
of the wrongest bets of how time I mean
if we look back probably in the last
maybe 20 years that was probably the
worst kind
equation we could have made not only did
it not pan out it got worse I think
China has built a system that is semi
capitalist its state capitalist for sure
but it remained autocratic and almost
every other facet of life but now it has
technology to to almost make that you
know authoritarianism even more
efficient and even more totalitarian
because technology is just this great
enabler and now which is what the NBA
issue has been showing and other things
like its control of Hollywood its
exporting that to the United States I
mean that's that's the scary part it's
that they're able to influence from afar
what you know what people beyond their
borders can [ __ ] can say I mean the fact
that they could get daryl morey to kind
of make this follow-up grumbling tweet
that oh you know what this is just one
perspective out of many interpretations
of Hong Kong events and and that was
just such a you know it's just terrible
to see because you know where he stands
it was pretty clear where he stood
before and now this poor guy had a
basically backtrack because of business
implications to to his team which were
huge I mean they're not insignificant I
think every single Chinese sponsor
pulled out of the Houston Rockets the
CCTV canceled the their games like how
the Chinese national broadcaster yeah
and in $0.10 which was you know
basically in a contract with the NBA for
1.5 million dollars over five years to
digitally stream the games
cancel the screening of the preseason
games and and then you had shoe
companies pulling out and it's just it
was a whole boycott any talk about
cancel culture hmm this was the ultimate
cancel culture right and and even ninety
stores in China were pulling NBA and
Rockets merchandise and it's like this
is Nike you you know you have your
American company have some I mean for
lack of better word balls
don't let China neuter
the West it's it's kind of ridiculous
well it's easy to hate Trump isn't it my
newer when you awoke company right and
exactly so 90s like that but saw was the
NBA to some extent the NBA previously
had used the all-star game in in North
Carolina that was going to be played in
Charlotte North Carolina to pressure the
North Carolina government to to sort of
do something with the bathroom bills
like to introduce gender-neutral
bathrooms and the NBA has always been in
a way I mean to their credit I think
allowed its players to speak up whatever
it was politically right so you had
players like LeBron James and others
like even Steph Curry who had been
critical to president they never wanted
to go to the White House if they won the
championship but they were critical
about the United States for race
relations inequality and things like
that they spoke out even the coaches
well the Bron called Donald Trump a bomb
right yeah exactly yeah well the Obama
also called Kanye a jackass before I
remember that but there's more I mean
Steve Kerr has been outspoken on gun
control immigration immigration both him
and Gregg Popovich who talked about race
stuff so the NBA has allowed people to
speak for a moment China right pops up
suddenly it was not okay yeah right and
the and and that's the thing because it
costs them nothing to allow woke sort of
activism in the league right it did not
cost them anything in fact might even
help yeah but when it came to China it
actually cost them and that's where they
failed I mean to the credit of Adam
silver at least the Commissioner you
seem to only say we're not going to
sanction the Rockets they're allowed to
say whatever they want that's what abs
or said in a press conference however
the official apology
the official tweet after the NBA by the
NBA himself there statement was frankly
for me left that wouldn't left much to
be desired because it was kind of
different in Chinese in English and the
trees tweet yeah quema
more aggressive seeing apologizing for
hurting the feelings of the Chinese
people and said that mores comments were
extremely inappropriate so there was a
lot more they definitely took a value
stand against against what more I said
and and then also acknowledged that it
hurt the you know feelings of the
Chinese people and that just reminds me
of the kind of sort of landscape we have
to navigate here where a fence is
basically enough for us to kowtow to
outraged culture this is outrage culture
but the consequences are much bigger
well it's the whatnot of the work we've
been all the Chinese like freedom of
speech do they really can imagine
hurting 1.4 billion people's feelings
yeah you think we people get upset with
us when we're on stage we say something
controversial I know it's a type of
reach we can on each I knees government
does it's it's that it tries to present
the child obviously it presents the
Chinese people is completely monolithic
hmm and with control of media of
everything they can read and access and
entertainment you get something pretty
close to that you know you get something
pretty close to this complete uniformity
of thought because if you don't you get
sent to re-education cut exactly yeah
guys just a quick reminder that I'm
doing my show all well that ends well in
London the first data sold out the
second one this still got some tickets
available and I'm also in Brighton and
in Cambridge in November you can see the
links below in the description if you
want to see Francis he'll be at the
London show if you don't want to see him
he won't be at the Bryden in Cambridge
so if you want to see a good show come
to those absolutely so the ones that
you're going to need to buy tickets for
are Brighton and Cambridge because I'm
not going to be there so concerts in its
just relying on his comedy so please
please buy those tickets
yeah I'll even [ __ ] take that come
buy the ticket
so for starters I would say that in
general Chinese people and culture its
pragmatic so if you look at Maslow's
hierarchy of needs
hmm if you have your first few tiers met
and met pretty well because of all the
affluence in China nothing else really
matters its materialistic you basically
are working to to you know I mean look
at look at the luxury market its
conspicuous consumption in China you
basically in like certain you know small
locust of baby Beijing or Shanghai you
have countless Louie Vuitton late you
know I don't know why small area t's for
Louis Vuitton stores but there it is and
and that says something you know about
about what people value and chase after
and also why the luxury brands actually
count out to China a lot Dolce & Gabbana
and recently I think it was Versace had
to apologize because I think they had
they listed cities that they were in our
countries that they were in and they
listed China and Taiwan and Macau
separately and China said excuse me
those are all China so get rid of that
and they did but life there is is you
know I mean there's a huge middle class
and people are only starting to get used
to new money they eat well they enjoy
you know the good life I mean a huge
disparity by the way between the cities
and not cities huge and that is often
overlooked it's cuz everyone thinks of
China is this future but there is a huge
you know futuristic kind of like
beautiful skyscrapers but there is a
huge disparity between the rural and and
the city folk but the only thing that
you can't do is not criticize the
government not you know there's it used
to be that there were the three T's so
you couldn't say Tiananmen you couldn't
say Tibet and the last he was I can't
remember now Taiwan sorry and now of
course the the three T's have grown into
other things that they're sensitive for
example Winnie the Pooh cannot be said
or referred to because si Jinping who is
now leader for life a ruler of the
Communist Party
um somebody had kind of pointed out that
he bore a striking resemblance to Winnie
the Pooh so now all references to we
need a poo on me on Weibo
on WeChat any anything in China is now
scrubbed which is why if you watch the
latest South Park episode I don't want
to help I don't want to reveal any
spoilers but we need the poo feature is
quite a bit it is really one after China
I think that a few factors one is I mean
China I think si Jinping only got his
term really got extended to Eternity
only in 2017 so that was a more recent I
think China the the Congress that
gathered in 2017 was kind of the the
period where where it woke most people
in government up to at least like okay
they're remaining on this autocratic
path since then they've become more
belligerent in terms of territorial
disputes claiming you know islands and
and will building areas in the South
China Sea which has really angered many
regional countries so Philippines
Vietnam Singapore and really angry about
about what's happening in their corner
of the world because well they can
directly see China's increasing
ambitions and are very wary of that and
I think since then you know slowly
there's been an awakening but it's but
it was kind of remain in the political
realm it wasn't really until I think
like you said Hong Kong that look that
many people really started paying
attention to all the broader issues that
there might be another reason why you
know people were hesitant to sort of did
some China I think it was partly a fear
of being racist mm-hmm
I you know if had it been Russia doing
the same things
no no qualms there to criticize Russia
yes it also it's easier for Western
countries white countries to be
criticizing fellow white countries and
it is to be critical about you know this
is the problem with the rubric of seeing
everything through people of color and
intersectionality but there are Chinese
people people of color Asian Americans
are not now I think that's because they
regards but Chinese very much so
right and by the way chinese state media
loves to play race card and listen
really okay they absolutely play the
victim high culture so in in so when you
if you go to school in China yeah you
are taught from a young age
through their state and forced education
about the opium wars about the
hundred-year humiliation about how the
West may China sell Macau and Hong Kong
and so that's why returning Hong Kong
was such a big fu to to the past so they
do play up there you know their
humiliation at Western powers hands
because they want to try to drum up
patriotism because once they do that I
mean think about like if you built like
a uma Chinese OMA which was also a
subject of another piece that I wrote
for spectator where basically it's like
a hive mind all you need to do is just
press the button of patriotism and like
the Chinese armies will just rise and
just attack and just you know embrace
come to the same position and now the
government has unilateral power to
basically do what they want what do you
think is going to be the Chinese program
in the coming years can you just see
them wanting to expand their power base
yeah and get their tentacles as widely
spread as possible yeah they're going I
mean especially through technology they
you know with if Silicon Valley does not
act on principle
and I'm worried about that it's going to
get worse you were already worried about
censorship on social media platforms but
once they're in bed with China or have
Chinese investment how are they going to
act right you know and and I think my
biggest worry is actually AI it's China
is spending if you look at in all the
areas where China's putting money on and
in AI they're out spending the u.s. in
terms of investing and developing the
technology ai companies and what's gonna
happen when that technology really
becomes ripe is they're going to have
first dibs and the power to you know
effectively either export their techno
surveillance state to to the rest of the
world
it is and I think Trump has expanded
what he calls the national innovation
security base so he's actually starting
to expand like the kinds of companies in
which he's considering you know sort of
preventing trade between our dealings
between or at least screwed having more
scrutiny on companies with that kind of
dealings with China because this is
really a rising concern and apart from
economic sanctions what else you have
military options I mean as far as that
goes it's one of those things that
everyone wants to kind of stay out of
and so the only choice left is it's
really economic and China's playing the
same game they know that and that's why
they're using think of all the
propaganda the the way that they've
really managed to you know infiltrate
Hollywood because of just buying out
Hollywood studios outright smuggling
their their message into movies and and
because you have buying power you're
able to sort of say all right can you
remember this movie I think it was dr.
Strangelove yeah oh yeah yes a monk it
was like the character in dr.
Strangelove was a Tibetan monk played by
I'm really bad with actresses and and
actors but Tilda Swinton yeah Tilda
Swinton okay eventually was moved she
played him because they couldn't have a
Tibetan monk in the story because it's
one of the three T's right you're not
allowed to talk about Tibet and and
that's just a sensitive issue so she her
character was written in and kind of
changed modified to appease Chinese
censors this has happened so many times
I mean I don't know if there's like a
website cataloging all the ways in which
Hollywood has count out to China but
there should be there should be a
website cataloging every single company
from Delta Airlines to Qantas airlines
and Marriott hotels who fired people or
you know capitulated in the same way
because the effect is I mean it's
growing like the people that are just
you know being sort of victims of of
this kind of really it's Chinese
political correctness it's it's you know
this is our orthodoxy if you
do not conform its well you're going to
pay for it somehow
right right and I had a friend of mine
who was Miss World Canada
her name is Anastasio Lin she's off
Chinese descent and she did very
critical of the Chinese government she
actually was one of the major activists
sort of bringing attention to the organ
harvesting issue and also the treatment
of the following going at the hands of
the Chinese government she the Miss
World competition was slated to have
taken place in Beijing and because it
was there she couldn't go they they
actually cancelled her passport they
banned her from the country so she
couldn't even compete in her own pageant
and the worst part was they started
going after her family that way so
that's what you know if you look at
autocratic regimes around the world
turkeys or the one China CCP that's
exactly what they do I mean say what you
want about the West one of the things we
don't do if it's this like we'll go
after your family if you were a
dissident so for example Edward Snowden
his family is not affected his family's
not disappeared and kidnapped and tried
and and harmed or or hit their
livelihood is destroyed and they're not
jailed he's responsible for his actions
only and it ends there right individuals
but that's not the case they in China
they use this you know if you're if
you're a member of the Chinese dies for
a chances are your family they're lucky
I don't so I could say what I want but I
I couldn't if I had you know one or two
relatives that were living in China they
would absolutely be gone just based on
three articles I written so there are I
think I mean four I actually was a huge
supporter of the trade war as we need to
make China feel the pain economically I
know it's gonna cause us pain too but
it's one of those things where if we
don't use that I don't know what else
the other thing is businesses right so
not just the government but really
businesses need to be more aware of this
and and take responsibility for for
standing on values not surrendering
those to profit motives
there are other trading partners that we
can I know you won't have access to the
Chinese market but I don't think it's
worth it I don't think the end result is
going to be worth it when all of us are
sitting in gulags yeah
it's I don't know what price these
people are willing to pay or maybe
they're just trying to kick the can down
the road to the next generation to deal
with but seeing how China runs its own
country if you know that that's going to
be what's in store for the whole world
do we want to go there and will we ever
accept you know could we have a boycott
divestment kind of system from China
something like that
you know but this needs to be talked
about and and not kowtow me especially
to their you know what they're doing
with like trying to force people like
Moray to cancel tweets and to change
their minds what South Park did by the
way brilliant we need more of that in
one episode I think more people were
educated about Chinese influence in
Hollywood Chinese influence everywhere
even the weavers the plight of the
weavers were actually featured in a
South Park cartoon and we need more
people in the entertainment industry to
kind of tell these stories you know
sound the warning bells and in a symbol
I don't know an alliance of people that
just do not want to live under a world
order that china control
yeah numbers are hard to trust from an
authoritative country like China right
they fledge things and also there
they're able to use their currency to
sort of manipulate how things look I
would say the other thing that that I
read recently which sort of supports
your theory is that China is a severely
aging population and so by 2033 the
number of people that are in certain
working age range in the United States
is already going to outpace the number
in China and so therefore we don't
really have that much to worry about
because their economy isn't growing or
it's going to it's not the economic
juggernaut that we we thought it was
I've heard about that too
I will say that free trade you know if
it's REIT rate China wins if it's fair
trade the United States wins
that's exactly Donald Trump's message
ironic isn't it
ironically yeah you know Trump support
if you don't mind me asking um I did not
like it when he got into office I
absolutely find his personality
troubling repulsive for me personally
but I don't I never I never really
support candidates or pulp like I don't
support things that are like just
alright I'm Pro Hillary or Pro Trump
because what if they did something that
you agreed with yeah you know what if
Trump was good on say advancing the
cause of LGBT equality then you're gonna
because you would add to our Trump now
you have to oppose that which we do see
that a lot to see that exactly how to be
tribal right yeah so I've always gone by
Death things that Trump has done I like
the things that I absolutely do not like
especially right now with what he's
doing with Kurds and pulling out
military do not like that but especially
a bit ending a huh or allies that helps
us to fight Isis but on China he's been
actually pretty good and I cannot
imagine any other president being as
strong on China as he has been
rhetorically and and also just in terms
of policy I really like him to say more
about Hong Kong and and do more but I'm
not sure what that is and if you can't
propose a solution then clearly all the
smart people in the White House you know
are putting their brains together to
figure this out and who knows right and
if you think of the ongoing impeachment
trial I think that will end up China is
celebrating right it's gonna be really
happy about about Trump leaving office
because edium today China is a you know
is a very it's steeped in honor culture
there's this notion in in Chinese
culture about saving face and Trump has
no shame and he really does not allow
China to save face he he speaks ill of
it he he basically really rankles China
exactly where it hurts the most
and because he doesn't play by
the rules and he's just abrasive so
really annoys China on a level that's
almost visceral culturally and you know
the question for foreign policy experts
is is that a good thing you know
does China behave better when we're
nicer to them that's it but over the
years it's proven that that's not the
case we've we've been nice so then we've
trade it with them we allow them into
the WTO they didn't play nice they never
did so what's you know maybe it's time
for a different sort of tactics I think
that's what Trump brings to the table at
least in China specifically and it you
talked earlier about an axis and allies
coming back to the new Cold War I guess
the the universal constant jr. called
war is that both parties kind of knew
that the Soviet Union was yeah an
adversary right is that where we need to
get to do so over time I think so and I
think you know one of the most striking
things that to me at least was when the
UN was in session and they wanted to
criticize what was going on in in
Scindia which where the weavers were
being imprisoned and you look at all the
countries that did not sign the rebuke
against China
it was majority Muslim countries
Pakistan did not sign it many of the
Gulf states did not sign it and and the
people that were the most vocal about
the mistreatment of weaker Muslims were
New Zealand Australia the United United
Kingdom the United States you know the
evil West and and somehow the narrative
that that they are the ones who are
Islamophobic mm-hmm you know and somehow
the majority Muslim countries even
Turkey and the wiggers are of Turkic
descent did not stand up for them I mean
this is like what are we living in this
upside-down worlds right now in a way
and you can see how China because of the
belt and Road initiative has many
countries basically by the balls
yeah because of the sheer amount of
investment they have in in their country
I mean just today I thought in the last
two days presidency Jinping was actually
in Nepal because he you know I think was
a 500 million dollar investment in Nepal
and and this is a country that's you
know where the Tibet is there and Dalai
Lama got excised and you see the Welcome
that they gave him and he gave a press
conference saying that if hope if you
know if Hong Kong continues to happen
that they will be crushed bodies and
bones
he said that in Nepal and the warm
welcome that they gave him is pretty
much related to the investment that he
was bringing to this country and and
with the bail and wrote initiative
investments in Africa now even South
America that they're expanding to who
knows who's influenced who knows whose
loyalty the Chinese could buy it's scary
and that's why the West needs to make us
then
it's what Peter Boghossian was saying
about scales right I think yesterday one
of his talks he talked about okay so you
want to talk about the patriarchy where
is say Saudi Arabia because we want to
qualify what you need by yeah why we
live in this you know in these times so
I mean as we are aware of you know all
these walk antics here I think the sense
of proportionality is in order
there is canceled culture outraged
culture and all these and patriarchy and
rape culture on a very different scale
elsewhere and we lose proportionality
when we're focused on on issues here
that by comparison are are not are just
not as severe no I'm guessing great
great culture and sounds done is a lot
worse than American College campus not
to say doesn't exist always have to say
that yeah I understand yeah
yes absolutely go to go to Singapore go
to Indonesia there are a lot of other
Asian democracies near China that have
the rule of law that enforced
intellectual property rights that play
fair do that you know the issue
obviously is that then they won't have
access to the Chinese market so the
willingness to do that is probably very
low if you're going to be you know if
you have fiduciary responsibilities your
shareholders so I hope that that's what
they do but I can't see that being
across the board it's just too lucrative
democracy and whether or not
authoritative an advantage because they
are a power longer so Thomas Hobbes
Leviathan mm-hmm and how that plays and
how that contrasts with systems that we
have that we assume are good systems
liberal democracy right this is kind of
the struggle of our time obviously I
grew up in Singapore and we've had one
party in power since independence 1965
and the country went from third world
first well in my own lifetime it's it's
almost nation-building at its best and
it was done by having this longevity of
having if there was a tumultuous system
in which the parties were changing and
it's unlikely that could have been
possible and so one of the things we
don't talk about is perhaps you know
what are the merits of these two systems
I mean we talk about an impending clash
this new clash of civilizations will
orders well what did they get right and
can we design systems even as we cherish
you know our liberalism and our
democracy here that can at least give us
some of that mmm what do you mean can
you give me an example well so for
example is is the system that we have in
Congress where especially now
exacerbated by the media cycle where you
basically have to campaign every two
years it seems mm-hmm that that cannot
be good for that's why our potholes are
not fixed that's why our airports suck
you know one of things I definitely
greet with Trump was that he said that
LaGuardia and Newark airports were like
third world countries at airports I mean
then you go to places like Bangkok and
they've got this sprawling you know
glass beautiful airports around the
world some when I first immigrated to
the United States it felt like a bit of
a downgrade I was like this feels like
there will contain many respects and
with with long term planning you can
really do things like urban planning
land use
you know regulation that that are just
far more they're farsighted they assume
that people are actually going to still
be there and
gonna be there in 20 years and and
they're gonna be able to judge and
select for for the better ideas in a way
that just we aren't so are their systems
policies that can mimic that but still
retain our political freedoms and still
retain our right to free speech which i
think is so so so important and cannot
be compromised on thanks for watching
guys as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pop and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word
[Music]
[Music]